over the moon to see you first of all
you look absolutely gorgeous and this
song is beyond rumors the vibe yes yes
yes
everything it is so good uh when did you
write this song
i wrote the song in february
of 2021
i have been waiting to drop this since
february i'm like where can i put it out
but we've been working on it for a long
time yeah because the first version of
it was like super simple and like rock
rock and roll and yeah you know it's
gone through so many different versions
and then we added the horns and then we
added cardi b
and
and it's become this like
mega hit now yeah can we talk about that
the cardi b situation i mean fans are
going to go crazy the fact that you guys
are collaborating together i mean
everyone wants this to happen you're
supposed to be in the wab video and here
we are so who called who who texted like
how did it all happen
i definitely called cardi because
she's i mean
she's incredible i've been wanting to
work with her for years ask anybody in
atlantic i was like the day she got
signed i was like i want a song like
hearty me so um when i finally had a
song you know on the level
yeah um that was perfect for us i hit
her up and sent it to her and she loved
it and
you know sent her verse through like you
know because of kobe we couldn't be
together but we facetimed and the rest
is um
herstory
yeah right and you know i met cardi b a
few years ago you know what i love about
her she's just authentically her it's
just that's who she is i mean what has
it meant for you to have her
friendship through this journey where
you're making a career in music
you know she's very very supportive and
she has really really smart advice like
i feel like she's just so tapped into
everything to the world that she can
look at you and be like hey you know
she's like she can feel it she can be
like you
don't don't
get discouraged when this happens and
you know keep doing this and she's
always like that like in my dm she's
like you're nexus like
you know you need to come back we miss
you like she's she's a cheerleader you
know and um it really means a lot
does this mean you'll be releasing a
video with her um i mean she has a
little baby bump as well are you guys
gonna be together how's it original
did you do are you guys have been on set
already
oh um yeah we made a music video
oh
and she's pregnant and all of that it's
all of it
cardi and cardi junior
world i'm melting right now oh my
goodness i'm still melting
like an hour when i when i saw her i was
like oh my god
and i was breaking down the song and you
mentioned our canadian boy drake in the
song are you excited about him hearing
us
listen
you know what he's probably already
heard it knowing him he's great
i can't wait for his reaction to it uh
but a serious question what does chris
evans think of the song
that's your serious question that's my
serious question what are you ready for
the drinks i mean you're supposed to
have shots together
i know i can't wait i'm literally gonna
make that happen i don't care i don't
care
um
he he has not heard the song um i don't
know what he thinks of the song and
if he does hear the song uh i'll let you
know
i love that um i love the fact that he
called the song rumors i mean you
recently you've acknowledged rumors so
the whole stage died thing and on tick
tock but what has been the most insane
thing you've heard that's almost
laughable
um
[Music]
i mean you kind of nailed a couple of
them the stage diving thing was
annoying um
chris evan being pregnant with chris
evans child i was like come on guys like
what
you know they're always putting me in
some weird like one direction love
triangle i'm just like i don't know
what's happening
um
i i don't know i think i think
i think everything is pretty silly i
don't take any of yeah
that's good and how do you deal with
negative comments i'm always curious to
see how you just kind of
not let affect you
um
it bothers me there's there's a time
limit on how long things like this can
bother you if you allow them for me like
when i hear it or if i see it
i have to put it away and it's going to
bother me for
20 to 30 minutes like i can feel it in
my head and in my chest
and then
eventually something else is gonna
happen that distracts me or takes my
mind off of it and i'm gonna feel better
and i think that's the key there
reminding yourself i'm going to feel
better you know this is bothering me now
but once i'm over this
i don't ever have to look at that again
i don't read comments though at all you
don't read comments
you avoid them that's that's a good way
to take i need to learn how to do that i
need to learn how to not let things
affect me and uh you know i just want to
say thank you for to you for being so
real and
being so open and while having fun with
it what does it mean for you to be able
to be this inspiration to so many women
um i think it's
very cool i mean i'm just being myself
i'm just living my life i'm just trying
to do the right things all the time
which i don't always do you know and i
can't promise that i always will
but um
it's a special relationship to
inspire people i mean i'm just as
inspired you know so
it's a very pleasant cycle i'm inspiring
you you're inspiring me to continue to
inspire and now everyone's inspired now
everyone's inspiring a lot of people are
gonna be inspired i understand that
you're working on a new album
and we got this new song
and i'm assuming this is the type of
journey we'll be going on with this
album is that right
um
you know i've never been the type to go
to preachy i just kind of talk about
things that happen to me this album is a
lot of fun
like i'm having a lot of like
like
what you get for that is what you get
you know what's the name of the album
girl what
there isn't an album yet there's just
like a hundred years
if you yeah if you were to name it what
would you name it
hmm
i don't know
i don't know big i think about it
big bank account big ass even bigger
hair
yes
oh there you go
is there gonna be collaborations on this
album um cardi b is the only
um collab so far but i do want more so
we'll see what happens okay and who who
do you want to have have to be on the
album with you
um
is that is that cardi b right now
beyonce
can we talk about that when i think
about all your success i think back to
the grammys where you're hanging out
with harry styles you're presenting to
megan the stallion beyonce's there so
please tell me you had your beyonce
moment did you meet her did you talk to
her
tell me it happened
no i left
i left before she came and i was so
i was like what
why do i keep crossing paths with this
woman and not meeting her but i also
don't want to meet her because i'm so
scared like she's like i grew up
watching her so i'm just like what i
even say to you like hey
uh remember papadopoulos in houston like
what do we say to beyonce you know i
don't know
is that your ultimate dream to
collaborate with her
um
i think my dream is to carry a
conversation with her without saying
anything dumb
that's the dream
i love that and so with this new album
how are you feeling about putting new
music out especially at a time like this
where people have been going through a
lot mentally physically and spiritually
but just bringing that joy to them
well you know what i i take that into
heavy consideration when i'm making
music because of course i'm saying all
the things i want to say but sometimes i
think about what do people need to hear
or want to hear right now and um
i
use music as therapy to make myself feel
good and get myself through and um
you know i want to put out music that
can do the same for people
will you be using your flute for this
album
oh my goodness my flute sasha has been
um
going through renegotiations with her
management and um her label
so she's just like super expensive right
now and it's been really hard to get her
in the studio without paying for glam a
driver her rider and her like studio fee
she's like such a fiva so
lizzo how do you define success i mean
you've gone through so much in your
journey but so open about everything
that you've gone through to get to this
point but what's your definition of
success
um
[Music]
and she laughs
no i'm laughing just because sasha flews
um
[Applause]
no my definition of success i think is
i
i truly believe i was successful a long
time ago when i was able to quit
working at a restaurant
and i was able to support my family
and myself through music alone
when i was able to successfully tour i
remember i grossed a million dollars on
my tour
um
i think in maybe 2017
or something like that 16 or 17 and i
was like wow i really i'm successful
like i did this on my own you know with
a great team
but
that was it for me so anything after
that is just kind of like huh
how did i get here like you know success
to me is just like
when you're doing the said you the
you're doing the thing you said you
wanted to do and you're doing it
abundantly and you're happy
i love that
and when you were 21 you talk about
everything that you went through that
was one of your hardest years in your
life and you grew from that um
what have you carried from i guess that
year to now that you always keep near to
your heart
um
appreciation for life and
i'm in gratitude like i always think
like oh my gosh i can't believe like i
was
in such a dark place and you know 2000
and whatever or whatever yeah we won and
like
i
um
am like
i'm just glad i'm not there anymore i'm
just glad you know i just every day i'm
like i'm just happy to be here because i
was there and i don't want to be here
anymore
yeah
and i have to tell you i love watching
you on tech talk um i think you are one
of the best tick-tockers out there is
that a word tick-tockers uh there are
you
i am not a tick-tocker i am a person
with a tick-tock but there are
tick-tockers tick-tockers are you
obsessed with it
yeah i'm on it all the time
people have people that
like artists have like
people who run their tick tocks for them
and you know their labels tell them what
to do a lot of times yeah people be
surprised when i'm like no i'll just be
on here all the time i just we all hear
comments on people's things like that
looks good they're like what are you
doing commenting on my video i'm like i
don't know i'm just
[Laughter]
like
you're amazing you're like on top of it
all of it i love it uh what does it mean
to have music in your life
well i mean i guess music is my life i
know that sounds cliche but you know i
would not
be here if it weren't for music like i'm
so grateful for it and
um it's in me and uh because it's in me
i can
put it out into the world
yeah and with this new album how are you
feeling about your fans have you
responded to what they wanted i know a
lot of them kind of say this type of
music this is type of music but do you
think they'll be the fans will be happy
with the new album coming out
um yeah i mean i think that
fans of me
have grown with me
and this is going to be
growth more growth we can all just grow
together
i love you you are amazing keep being
you and uh my kids love you everyone
loves you you are just amazing and uh
really i appreciate you mwah appreciate
you as well thank you for your time
thank you congratulations thanks
everybody bye bye